the president's trip to Huntington West
Virginia last night feature another
all-out defense of his campaign he told
thousands of supporters that Democrats
are obsessed with the idea that his
campaign had ties to Russia the
president also called the ongoing
investigation demeaning to the
Constitution
major Garrett is at the White House
matric morning to you good morning White
House lawyers brushed off the creation
of this grand jury as no big deal and in
West Virginia at a venue the president
really likes I mean a campaign style
rally he said the focus on him on Russia
is denying those supporters effective
and functioning governing and he said
the real target ought to be his former
Democratic rival are there any Russians
here tonight any Russians President
Trump mocked ongoing questions and
investigations into possible campaign
collusion with Russians there were no
Russians in our campaign that never were
we didn't win because of Russia we won
because of you that I can tell you of
course mr. Trump has never been accused
of having Russians on his staff
investigators are probing campaign and
financial links instead the president
said it's all about trying to derail his
administration they're trying to cheat
you out of the leadership you want with
a fake story that is demeaning to all of
us and most importantly demeaning to our
country and demeaning to our
Constitution mr. Trump instead demanded
an investigation into the long since
vanquished Democratic nominee what the
prosecutors should be looking at are
Hillary Clinton's 33
one week after Senate Republican efforts
to repeal and replace Obamacare failed
the president turned on both parties
honestly how the Republicans and the
Democrats let us down on that is hard to
believe repeal and replace hard to
believe long a proponent of his unique
ability to generate change the president
asked for grassroots support call your
Congressman call your senators call
everybody get him to have the guts to
vote to repeal and replace Obamacare
also last night the president said he
hoped the Muller investigation will be
conducted honestly implying Margaret
he's not necessarily convinced it will
be major thank you